ou sur twitter la gauche peut-elle
gagner les prochaines élections
présidentielle et législatives si on
pose la question c'est qu'il ya trois
éléments
que l'on partage d'abord les victoires
enregistrées par la gauche aux
régionales en métropole et en outre-mer
vous avez pu le voir dans le figaro ce
matin il ya huit super régions qui sont
détenues par la gauche cet par la droite
alors effectivement il faut compter les
outre mer en plus cette des trois
régions d'outre-mer
ensuite il ya une autre image dimanche
soir où malgré la défaite on a vu
l'écologiste bayou l'insoumise hautain
et la socialiste pulvar tout sourire
applaudissant main dans la main célébrer
l'unité retrouvée et enfin il ya cet
échange à 24 heures d'intervalle entre
dominique reynié qui dit que le pays se
droitise et la réplique ce matin dallas
mac
je vous propose d'écouter cet échange a
chez sonia mabrouk la france se droitise
électoralement on le voit à travers des
scrutins comme celui là même s'il faut
garder à l'esprit l'abstention et puis à
travers les préoccupations préoccupation
pour la sécurité préoccupation pour les
migrations
la question des valeurs aussi je
signerai européenne il ya une
droitisation de l'europe et c'est pas il
faut pas chercher dans les sondages
seulement cette droitisation il faut
surtout la regarder dans les scrutins
on va avoir ce ce processus qui va se
déployer jusqu'en 2022
je suis pas convaincu de singe la preuve
en est que la gauche fait un score
considérable et c'est pas une gauche
droitisée c'est une gauche racialisée
certes pour une part mais pas droitiser
je crois qu'en réalité il faut revoir la
scène telle qu'elle était au départ ça
parce que c'est nos espérances on est un
petit peu plus loin mais en tous les cas
le vous aimeriez partager le point de
vue de la main que moi j'ai toujours
pensé que
le clivage droite gauche comme on y
était le seul qui structurent vraiment
la vie politique il ya des il ya des
questions transversales qui kiss & kill
que l'europe comme la question de
l'ouverture des frontières ou de la
fermeture on le ski qui divise les deux
camps mais il reste quand même deux
camps et et toutes les démocraties
pratique des corps sont toujours
structuré comme ça mais ils sont quand
partir de la droite radicale à la droite
a gagné cette élection c'est vrai ça
bahia en fassiez une gauche et quand on
regarde les voix qui se sont exprimées
sur le prénom il ya beaucoup
d'abstention avait bien compris ceux qui
sont exprimés la gauche c'est le
deuxième ensemble dans une partie
puisque plus en partie mais c'est le
deuxième ensemble avec beaucoup de voix
finale de pas mal le seul et le simple
fait que vous posez la question montrent
que ça commence à changer
comment vous interpréter cette
performance est ce que c'est une
résistance
c'est finalement un retour finalement a
je pense qu'on a sous-estimé pendant
cette campagne la question sociale qu on
a parlé beaucoup de sécurité beaucoup
d'immigration bon jeu normal qu'on en
parle surtout sur les droites mais mais
en plus c'est des vrais problèmes mais
on a complètement oublié les salaires le
chômage l'emploi avant d'en parler un
peu mais c'était hors ces questions-là
préoccupe les gens et c'est une
déception des questions sur les quais de
la gauche à tort ou à raison je pour
l'instant je ne dis pas je prenne la
propagande mais où la gauche dit des
choses ou est historiquement c'est quand
même ses thèmes de prédilection et ces
thèmes là sont importants de la même
manière chacun a compris que la crise
climatique était grave était importante
la gauche propose des solutions la crise
démocratique c'est la même chose la
gauche propose y en a qui proposent de
changer de république comme la france a
soumises doivent qui propose des
réformes revalorisation du parlement
l'intervention des citoyens dans la vie
politique
entre les élections tout ça existe tout
ça ce sont des choses dont on peut
débattre qui sont intéressantes
laurent mais est ce que ça signifie que
la gauche remonte de façon à ce que vous
ce que vous pouvez espérer gagner les
prochains scrutins
c'est pas entièrement exclue entièrement
exclue si vous avez parce que qui peut
gagner alors je vais pas vous dire des
noms mais simplement
on le voit dans cette élection qui qui a
vraiment gagné socialistes ont gardé
leurs cinq régions ont dit wamiz étaient
sortants oui mais jusqu'à présent on
disait que les sortants il fallait les
sortir
donc c'était plutôt un handicap de deux
sortants regardez alain rousset c'est
son cinquième mandat
il a été élu dans un fauteuil donc ça
veut dire que les gens les ont vus à
l'oeuvre et considère qu'ils font bien
leur travail et donc ils ont réélu bon
et c'est pourquoi il est pourquoi ils
l'ont fait ce but prenons le cas de
carole delga que je connais mieux que
roussey carole delga peut pas dire que
c'est le passé exceet en occitanie était
la mieux élue que la mieux élue du tout
tous elle mène une politique régionale
qui est écologique et sociale et
démocratique avec les écologistes ni
avec les justement quand ce sont les
écologistes alors ici c'est très bien
ils ont tant ils font la fête c'est
parfait mais quand c'est les écologistes
ça marche pas ça m'arrive au marché noir
ablement c'est quand les séquences et
quand vous avez un ou une candidate
socialiste raisonnable si je peux dire
que vous avez une passe qu'il faut
regagner des élections dévoile sur macro
ouais c'est avec des civils qu'on fait
des militaires donc il faut prendre des
voix à maquereau le général bresse par
le non non pas du tout moi je pense
qu'on est un peu en train de redécouvrir
la lune
il reste une gauche et une droite et une
gauche dans ce pays c'est évident ça
fait deux siècles et demi que ce concept
dont moi je crois comme
le rand qui qui structurent au delà de
structurer de façon organique et
structures de façon ils comment dire ils
nourrissent le débat démocratique et son
nécessaire débat démocratique donc que
c'est que la droite existe et que la
gauche existe on leur train de
redécouvrir
après une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'a pas
tout dit il que il faut regarder le
niveau de l'un et de l'autre
et malgré tout là je rejoins régner si
on veut ni craignez le politologue de la
fondapol si on regarde depuis une
dizaine d'années une quinzaine d'années
le rapport de force entre il reste une
gauche oui bien sûr et une gauche mais
le rapport de force entre le regret la
gauche en train d'évoluer fortement est
assez rapidement en france comme dans le
reste de l'europe en faveur de la droite
ça veut pas dire qu'il ya une gauche
celle d'une gauche qui peut ici ou là
atteindre 30 ou 40% et à venir avec toi
c'est beaucoup et la certitude de la
mort dans une régionales à la
proportionnelle où il ya des
triangulaires des cadres galons gagne 30
ou 40% mais autrefois en gros le rapport
de force droite gauche étaient 50 50 45
alors mettons 45 55 mais mais mais mais
mais d'ailleurs intuitivement le sent
bien on sent bien que la bataille à
trois se joue entre de l'extrême droite
de la droite et un maquereau qui est au
centre
alors les indices centre droit sont donc
au centre donc la bataille c est sa voix
de droite centre aujourd'hui donc on se
sent bien qu'il ya 3 il y a trois quarts
qui sont pas de gauche puis un quartier
de gauche grosso modo peut-être un tiers
avait mais par rapport à ce qu'a été ce
pays
c'est un recul de la gauche et
j'ajouterais et c'est là où je j'ai un
sérieux bémol par rapport à ce que dit
laurent en disant cette gauche pourrait
accéder
au saut vers la présidentielle au second
tour présente elle je dirais oui si elle
était unie si ce tiers étaient unis le
problème c'est que ce tiers est lui-même
divisé en trois morceaux de 10%
trois morceaux qui se pour l'instant
alors alors aujourd'hui il est et aux jo
et vous avez raison et ses trois
morceaux sont comment dire c'est pas
c'est pas comme la droite je veux pas
dire que du tout le droit de venir cette
armée la droite malgré tout entre
pécresse bertrand voquer ya des nuances
ils étaient au même lille sont pas
exactement dans le même parti puisqu'il
y en a deux qui viennent de son parti ne
soit enfin c'est la même famille
politique et à 80% que ils pensent la
même chose aujourd'hui entre les trois
morceaux de la gauche
le morceau socialiste le morceau écolo
et le morceau mélenchon nos communistes
il ya des divergences considérable des
oppositions d'appareils d'abord s'aider
machine électorale qui se combattent et
puis doctrinalement sait on pense pas la
même chose sur rémy c'est sur l'islam
sur le ca à gauche par ce point là entre
les sociétés comme s'il y avait une
différence de degré dû à mon grand âge
mais souvenez-vous du les rapports avec
les communes cia le défendeur qui
défendait mais dictature du prolétariat
oui mais leur défendent l urss le
rapport qui était composé souvent de
militants stalinien juifs ajdabiya
réussissent à réunifier tout ça il ya
vous fait des communistes oui bon je
suis venu c'est là où je voulais en
venir
il nous faut il vous faut il vous faut
votre mitterrand mais ce mitterrand là
il devra pas se contenter de fusionner
des gens qui sont pas d'accord sur
l'appropriation collective des moyens de
production
ça va être sur l'islam ça va être sur la
république ça va être le sur la
croissance ou la décroissance ça va être
sur le nucléaire ou pas le nucléaire
enfin les thèmes de d'opposition comment
dire et c'est pas médiocre eux il ya une
vision du monde écolo qui n'est vraiment
pas la même vision que la vision que les
écolos oui de la vision sociale
terroriser les insoumis qui sont
islamo-gauchiste racialiste ont
absolument rien à voir avec la gauche
républicaine qui est proche de manuel
valls
donc là il ya des c'est vraiment très
très très je vous dis pas que c'est
intellectuellement impossible mais ça me
paraît hors de vue pour cela prendre
oui c'est vrai
l excès alexis a raison s'il ya trois
parts égales
là il faut s'unir mais c'est difficile
ces divergences convient d'évoquer le
sont mais si ça veut dire que c'est pas
on reste également débat sur ondes il
faut il faut s'unir pour gagner mais
c'est la gauche n'a pas forcément gagné
quand elle était unique non mais ça je
suis d'accord mais la toule mitterrand
il a gagné et le pc les yeux
pratiquement dix ans sur lui hollande il
a gagné il y avait plusieurs candidats
de gauche ou cana qui arrive au second
tour à trois fois dix on n'arrive pas au
second tour à un vin et l'autre à 10 on
peut dire magnanac une perse et à mon
avis ça peut pas ça peut pas être ça
peut pas être vérifié vérifier elle-même
les écolos c'est tout la bataille les
écolos prétendent être au milieu si elle
ne savait pas ce que je vois dans le
scrutin dans le scrutin envoie deux
choses qui peut apporte de l'eau au
moulin et des uns et des autres les
services peuvent dire on a gagné les
régions c'est vrai et les écolos peuvent
dire c'est nous qui avons progressé et
c'est vrai aussi
et donc aujourd'hui les économies n'ont
pas progressé entre les deux tours
non ils ont progressé par rapport
l'année par rapport à l'anr fa ba oui et
la force qui montrent la force 1020 la
force kid s'est dit j'ai l'avenir pour
moi du point de vue des écolos c'est les
écolos mais ça fait le troisième ça fait
pas une majorité savent pas qui plafonne
à 30%
donc votre thèse si je vous suis c'est
quand même il faut que ce soit les céder
mais je vais être simple si c'est pas un
mine socialiste à mon avis ça marchera
pas et c'est une socialiste qui soit
écolo compatible il faut mais tout le
monde même la droite dit qu'elle est
écolo maintenant et est ce que justement
on n'a pas vu un autre phénomène montre
m'a frappé c'est les résultats enfin ce
qui s'est passé en ile de france dans
cette union effectivement derrière
julien bayou et et
et c'est cette prise de position à la
fois jean paul duchon de manuel valls
qui eux ont carrément sais c'est pas la
preuve qu'il ya vraiment ces fameux de
gauches irréconciliables et tout mettre
un peu vert malawi mais c'est quand même
bizarre de parler de gauches
irréconciliables alors qu'ils étaient
unis c'est curieux mais qui sont
conciliables non ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que quand ils arrivent de gauche
qui refusent de soutenir cette union de
la gauche
oui ils n'ont pas perdu de voix entre
les deux tours mais ils n'ont pas gagné
on pas gagné ce sont les écolos qui sont
arrivés devant louis d'un point à ben
oui mais vous dites vous il faudrait
surtout pas que tout le monde soit à
égalité or le problème en ile de france
oui c'est que ces douze pulvar 11 aux
côtés de disney qui serait trop
difficile
voilà si si c'est le fait ça si le
schéma qu'il ne font que répercuter
répercute ou ne s'est perdu et perdu en
accord qu'est ce que vous répondez juste
à cet internaute et laurent qui nous dit
c'est qui la gauche sort jadot delgado
hidalgo c'est 100% du maquereau que
compatibles et ça n'a aucune chance
jusqu'au bout
ces macro compatible cemac retrouvailles
mais ça a pas l'air lui ils sont aidés
dans huit ans dans la mission dans leur
position quand même donc et après si le
l'un de ses personnages et mon avis ça
ne peut être qu'un ou une socialiste se
détache ça change chose mais bon vu avec
son nez on en est loin
c'est difficile reconnaît que sur
l'apple chance sur le papier sur le
papier alors les internautes vont me
maudire mais je le dis quand même sur le
papier eu une anne hidalgo qui est
socialiste et qui est écolo compatible
je veux dire à pas est ce pourquoi pas
le problème c'est que ça fait un an
qu'on dise à un an qu'elle est à quelle
est leur rase razmoket dans les sondages
et est vrai fallait pas combien de
points sont d'accord et que ça se passe
pas très bien et que dans l'opinion
s'apprend pas que les rapports avec les
écolos ne sont pas si bons que ça et que
les rapports avec les mélanges sont
désastreux donc je sens bon ça fait
perdre des voix
je suis d'accord j'aurais envie de dire
que sur le papier c'est un fait
envisageable mais dans la réalité ça
marche pas or pour l'instant
celle qui est le plus qui sur le papier
si on est à l'extérieur comme je le suis
pour redire basse après tout elle est
socialiste carolo
j'attends avec impatience mais en tout
cas je pense que les internautes
préférons vous entendre dire anne
hidalgo peut-être une chance etc l afic
à la fin ne gagne pas plutôt que via n'a
pas de chance ces cas-là files pour
certains internautes si je lis certains
commentaires je l'avais dit le sort des
bleus j'avais écrit de santé municipal
en disant si si la socialiste arrive à
100 cas avec les écologistes
ouais ça fait des mois ça fait assez
pour un second tour
son arrivée un second taux absolu après
il faut trouver des réserves pour
faudrait des réserves pour le second
alain weill à un scénario macro
messieurs macron baisse la tête et
j'avais un ou une candidate socialiste
qui se retrouve au deuxième tour contre
marine le pen
voilà c'est fait nous mêmes proton que
ça fait beaucoup de si la droite comme
la gauche s'entendent mais il n'ya pas
nécessaire d'espérer contremaître un
paris en bouteille mais vous on a
compris que ça sera le label et le
millésime ce sera hidalgo
si on vous suit laurent la gauche
peut-elle gagner les élections
présidentielle et législatives alors
vous pronostiquez un nom à 81 2%
valentin nous dit je pense que la gauche
ne gagnera pas car les français sont
selon moi beaucoup préoccupé par des
questions de sécurité dans la droite
sont beaucoup mieux auquel la droite
semble mieux répondre veulent pas une
unité retrouvée mais pour combien de
temps
françois nous dit malheureusement non
trop de divisions et lui dit inutile
passé de choses en commun et carew donne
il faudrait déjà qu'ils s'accordent pour
trouver un candidat parce que séparément
chacun des partis de gauche peine
atteindre les 10%
le merci pour pour l'instant pour vos
contributions merci fonds sera réalisée
serrer le jeu et il faut beaucoup pour
désespérer merci vos cours djaka d'avoir
à analyser commenter débattu autour de
ces questions vous restez avec nous sur
figaro live dans quelques dans une heure
environ
un peu plus d'une heure vous aurez les
victoires de la croissance durable 5 de
cinq entrepreneurs qui viendront
justement présenter leur projet et un
jury leur accordera le prix de la
croissance durable
événement à suivre sur figaro live merci
beaucoup on se retrouve demain même
heure même endroit avec guillaume
roquette a très vite